I'm checking into a family-run lodge in
Island Park Idaho where business has
taken a toll on a married couple that
has lost their way we've had a lot of
hard years you know a lot of arguing I
know we're in trouble my struggle is not
only to fix the lodge that's 15 years of
dust wow is that blood but to renew the
passion that they once had the heart's
gone we need to get that back it's about
to clap
when I first came into the area I saw
this piece of land it was right next to
one of the world's best fly Fisheries
the Henry's Fork of the Snake River and
we jumped right on that piece of
property and started building the lodge
I thought I could fly fish while I had
the phone in my pocket taking
reservations
and that actually happened early on in
the early days in 1999.
[Music]
Dave would go cut the logs and peel the
logs sometimes he'd make our sons peel
some logs but they were pretty pretty
little growing up here was something
special we literally worked every aspect
of it I started out as a little kid
doing dishes and busting tables and then
waiting tables when we finally got the
lodge built and opened we would have
like two hour Waits and people loved it
loved it the lodge was full every single
night it was going so well that they
were getting ready to expand and then
that summer we lost my little brother he
was 10 years old when he died
[Music]
it was
dark it's a dark bad time
and my mom fell out
[Music]
when we lost that little boy our life
stopped
and I went to bed for three years
and I didn't I didn't get up
so without her here my dad was forced to
run everything by himself and that's
kind of the way he coped with everything
there was just a darkness and a sadness
that surrounded our family for years
business is quite slow I'd say it's
probably 25 percent compared to 100 back
then
Dave indeedy needs some help
Zach came back about a year ago to help
me run the restaurant and Lodge
he sees constantly how it's a struggle
for me to keep up with the restaurant
side so he came back to help
you take a young man you stick him in
there and you put him as a general
manager a general manager in my opinion
is somebody who needs to know the inside
and outside of the whole operation but
he doesn't know these things
Dave and I are tired and it's just like
a black hole for us and we don't want to
work this hard anymore make an income
back is our last hope it's my best hope
[Music]
I've just arrived at Island Park Idaho
and it is absolutely gorgeous this city
is nicknamed last chance because it
literally is the last place to stop for
food gas and lodgings before entering
Yellowstone National Park
and this location is one of the most
prestigious fly fishing areas anywhere
in the world it's a Fisherman's Paradise
the place go wrong look at that gorgeous
hello Hi how are you good Savannah
Gordon nice to see you wow
my goodness me this place is gorgeous
who built it my father no stop yeah
seriously their hands you are kidding me
wow yeah it's our family business we're
all doing it together wow um and
recently my oldest brother Zach took
over the restaurant so Zach's the
restaurant manager is mum and dad around
I'd love to meet them oh I'll follow you
wow look at those Beauties up there it's
a vegetarian nightmare up there yeah
let's fish everywhere yeah for real
Hello I'm Deedee how are you very nice
Preston good to see you
wow this is definitely a family-run
business right yes sir Gordon how are
you the gentle Giants with the Midas
touch by the looks of things
congratulations this place is gorgeous
thank you thank you did you build it
really I did building wow just had a
vision in my mind and we put things up
took them down until it looked great and
do you live on the property I do we have
a cabin right across the way just here
yeah don't tell me you built that as
well I did
where was the conversation you both had
when you decided to go ahead and build
it we found this all beat up buildings
there was a for sale sign on the back
side of it so we've made a deal and here
we are started building and what was the
dream did he what was the ambition well
you know we just love love the beautiful
River and we just started with boom you
know because of the beauty it's really
one of the most beautiful spots in Idaho
right and people just loved it so there
was like a two hour wait every night how
long ago was that how our first two
years wow like our first year two years
a long time ago so we got off to a great
start what happened then we had another
chef and then people got mad because we
changed the menu after that we had a
tragedy
after the tragedy my parents
just kind of checked out it was a really
hard time for my family and um I think
it showed in the lodge you know they
couldn't put their whole heart into it
because their heart was broken so are
you in love with it as much today as you
were 10 years ago I very proud of it and
I love it but I'm really tired right
we've been here a long time you know our
goal is to have the best restaurant in
the area and then 100 miles around but
through the years we've just lost
interest in that and he's really tired
you know he doesn't want to work that
hard anymore
so you're the Russian manager yes and
where did you train I worked at a few
really nice places when I was living in
San Diego that was where I probably
learned the most oh so you went away and
then came back I've been gone for about
nine years yeah right okay let me get to
the room and pack um sat why don't you
show me to the room yes sir
yes no what's that smell of lemon I'm
not sure God smell of lemon
I mean why on Earth would you need air
freshener in here with such beautiful uh
woof
yes the smell in here is crazy now let
me just call you out the window I guess
the back of your throat right yeah
um someone gonna make up the beds they
are made I've seen dog baskets uh better
how old are they they put in about five
years ago bloody hell seriously yeah
they're definitely old
is that blood I don't think so what is
that I'm not sure it's a stain anyway
wow okay so
um I'll be down in a couple of minutes
for a bite to eat sounds great yeah
would you recommend she does the rainbow
trout here what's her name her name is
Gina okay great thanks for updates
thanks Zach
wow
wow the view is breathtaking but the
color is depressing I mean honestly
everything's dark and gray and dingy and
the pillows look at those how uninviting
like the dog sat on it for the last 10
years really do smell
what is that
it's like a piece of candy stuck on the
pillow
it's terrible it's almost like they're
falling out of love
for this place and look at that oh big
dirty stain it's sad because it's almost
on the verge of being neglected and
you've got two owners that have clearly
run themselves into the ground you think
of a lodge in this area you think of
something that's cozy it's warm and
biting this is depressing oh dear
always a great way to find out how often
the place is cleaned
check out the filters
oh dear
that's
that's 15 years of dust
it's shipped in there turning something
off
it doesn't take much to clean that
hence the reason why this room stinks
of air freshener
[Music]
this is Gina Gina hey how are you oh so
nice to meet you nice to see you too
what do you think's wrong with the
business
staffing issues servers they're just
constantly late and you know I wouldn't
have a manager but Zack's the manager
yes he would come in at three or four
o'clock hey afternoon yeah what is that
day's fault is he tied uh does he not
want to put money into the business he
wants to be as Thrifty as possible yeah
you know this is your menu right you're
the chef so yeah I know so who dictates
this
Dave he never let anyone do the food
orders even no chefs really but he's
controlling you yes and controlling the
business tightly by the sounds of things
yeah Gina thank you thank you
does your dad realize when you build
something this unique then you need to
have a team to run it I don't think so
no I don't think he realizes at all he
doesn't know he doesn't know one bit
he's not he doesn't let them order their
own food ah no she watches every penny
is he that controlling he really wants
to watch what's being sent out and
what's being paid for the money
Zach please
excuse me thank you sir my pleasure
thank you very much
wings are for you sir with the homemade
Berry barbecue sauce wow thank you are
the wings fresh
I believe they come Frozen
yeah you can't buy fresh chicken locally
yeah
Bean served frozen food wasn't the start
I was looking for it looks like it's
been
dipped in else blood in fact the food
just kept getting worse pulling back
that rib eye is like pulling back that
duvet on my mattress the stain and
a strong in alcohol these are good wine
for this right all right
Gina claims her hands are tied in the
kitchen so at this point I don't know
who to blame
and rice is mush
who cooked that
oatmeal
what the [__] Idaho rainbow trout with
the herb risotto Jesus
what's all the uh squidgy bits around
the outside those are all the sauces all
the sauces yeah yeah seriously yeah
ah is that risotto or some of the
plaster that your dad left over from
building the new Lodge
it's still got the scales on it as well
why would you leave the skin that's
soggy like some used condom
that has to be the worst trout I've ever
seen in my entire career
wow does mum and dad see this food do
they come and have dinner they hate
everything they hate the
the dish or everything
they don't like the way that she does
anything and why is she here when you're
in the heat of the Season we kind of
just take what we can get you can't keep
on changing your Chef every year I agree
we do it every year [__] it now
if this place wasn't run by your parents
would you work here hell no not not for
a second I don't want to run a
restaurant have Kenai to get out I'm
desperate
and if you've got a job tomorrow would
you be off
yeah I feel like I've kind of done my
part the part that I told them that I
would do you're obviously concerned and
you're doing it more out of affection as
opposed to you really want to be here
sounds like your mind's made up
mm-hmm
wow
let's get them out please
would you both come out please both of
us did you come out
oh yeah what if I don't want to
Jeff Ramsey nice to meet you likewise
good to see you too
wow uh so I'm not the words
what feedback did you get throughout my
lunch
I didn't see anything nothing at all not
yet of course by course you didn't even
talk to them no why not I figured that
was what you were going to do when we
were done I was hoping at least you're
gonna say something to them so they can
up the game no I actually expecting to
say something and I thought well should
I ask or I kept thinking okay must be
okay I haven't heard any comments
don't you want the truth oh absolutely
do you know the owners hate your dishes
no you don't know the owners hate your
food no I did not know that you've got
no idea that DD can't stand the curry no
I never knew that
I feel like people have been lying to me
Gina I don't blame her let me I'm gonna
be frank
everybody was overcooked it looked like
we'd opened up the bottom of the
dishwasher and that plug was blocked
with bits of floating grease oh my God
you may find it funny but you're not
sure it was funny the way it was
described no but art I mean I'm not
trying to laugh about the river no no
but [__] now
look where we sat though
if you phone me on my telephone in the
car and ask me what do you think I'm
gonna be having I would never mention
those dishes
you did nothing to blow me away I'm
trying to use the ingredients that Dave
asked me to use a lot of it is cost so I
was tied to that
oh you're the sous chef is there any
Synergy in what you're doing no
doing it to survive no one's thinking
long term
it's stifling the business
I'm amazed you're still open
Zach I don't know if you've got one foot
in one foot out you shouldn't be here
yeah I've not been super invested that's
for sure get the [__] out of here
[Music]
so far I've learned that Dave and Dede
are checked out and Zach just doesn't
want to be here tonight at dinner
service I'm curious to see if Dave is
actually holding Gina back in the
kitchen
um
so Gina explain the line don't stop
working okay I work right here in the
saute area and then uh section doing the
burgers the steaks and Zach he mostly
stands behind the bar so he's not the
restaurant manager then he's the Batman
he's supposed to be
he went from the bottom to the top this
summer nothing in between but you don't
get support from him doesn't know how to
doesn't have to
what's the microwave for Gina uh to heat
the dip up not my choice but not my
choice to do a lot of things wow you're
the chef right yes so what you say goes
no should be chef
oh
Jesus Christ
[Music]
why ask did you make that no what is
that it's some kind of cheesecake
cheesecake looks like a landmine what
year is that from like 1800 he's 76. wow
ticket Karina please your salad will be
right up full time or part time
it's okay to chew gum in front of
customers or Dave just lets it go on
no it's very gross
and Zach I know you can't tell
Staffordshire but uh this young lady's
chewing gum I just I don't know you're
right yes no I know but um
it's
not typical no yes so yeah it's not
typical Laura please shoot the spit Your
Gun out thank you
thank you are you okay yeah I'm fine you
sure yeah you're good what's going on
here yeah you're right she didn't have
done absolutely
excuse me for just one second
what's going with everybody Curry though
I'm playing with the second chef but
don't you talk to each other so the food
can hit the window at the same time if
you open up and talk to Art then I can
take the sauce out of the container and
heat it up in a pot yeah Bill Hannah to
me I could do it right here I got lots
of time I'm doing it man there's a tiny
tiny chin trying to expedite this food
this so never needs to be this hard you
know that Gina
you don't like talking do you
um it's hard for me when I'm working I'm
sorry but you're doing desserts can the
young man do the desserts yes I know
everyone tells me I need to relinquish
responsibility guys I'm more capable you
can slice a cheesecake with his nice
clothes yes chef anyone can do it but
you prefer wasting time doing it
yourself I know just because it couldn't
get any worse the problem with this
Lodge is becoming more apparent there's
just no communication Gina doesn't speak
to the kitchen Dave and Dede ignore the
problems and Zach just doesn't know how
to take him out
oh man it was so dysfunctional yeah
oh is it
what did she say the chicken breast
chicken and pork she's like a new
chicken breast something absolutely
new chicken breast please
stop for two seconds yes sir Zach
awesome
well I just want you to touch that
touch it it's ice cold ice cold that's
what we resulted in sending you're just
drowned weighing over your head a mess a
big mess m-e-s
oh man
so I was underwhelmed and disappointed
you build this place to the absolute
spec beyond belief but I was
disappointed in my room the bed's
terrible Zach I pulled back the top
duvet and there was blood underneath the
duvet the air conditioning filters were
just full of [__] it was really shoddy
really shoddy and it broke my heart I
didn't even build the [__] place
and look at the Kitchen Tonight
what I don't get is the service and the
offering
because it was shocking the chicken goes
out ice cold slightly pink and nobody
cares
and that Dreadful cheesecake well that
cheesecake collapsed when I left the
kitchen get rid of it I was I did today
no you didn't
I know
nuts
you wrote that menu Gina I did you said
your hands were tied so you've got no
Freedom
um Dave gave me more freedom I believe
than he's given chefs in the past so so
you have free I'm just going on what you
told me I mean no I'm not talking about
chefs and listen you told me lunchtime
your hands were tied and you can't buy
anything you can't talk to suppliers and
what Dave says goes yes I mean basically
Dave do you handcuff Gina no I'm not a
handcuffed her only thing I try to do is
get her to cost compare you've got to
try to keep food costs lower are you
telling me that what you're sending is
value for money
it's no it's not nowhere near it am I
the only one that believes what we're
doing is incorrect
Zach you're not a restaurant manager
your heart's not in it young man
and I asked you one vital question
lunchtime if your parents didn't own
this restaurant would you be here and
immediately hell no
we're in trouble the largest around here
are more successful they're much more
successful and they're not even half as
lovely can I just have five minutes with
you do you mind okay let's go uh
[Music]
this is on a deck of cards at the moment
I feel it's about to collapse because
it's built with no infrastructure how's
the strain of the business affected you
and Dave
we've had a lot of really really hard
years you know a lot of arguing things
that I think are really important he
doesn't and vice versa why is he so
stubborn in a way that he's so
overbearing and so controlling I think
he's just really scared
to watch everything you know Dave wanted
Zach to kind of learn the business so
that in case anything happened to him
that we didn't lose everything and our
kids didn't lose anything all of our
investment right
and you probably know the terrible
things that we went through
well I Disappeared right because I
couldn't function so
he did it all himself he'd run the
Business Without Me and he did the best
he could and
he just did what he has to do and that's
what he does he does what he has
to do and he knew that I was gone and so
he
he ran up by himself
like this
his heart might be in the right place
but his head's not in the game
you've got the view the building's there
but right now it's just a shell it's had
better days for sure really really good
days in the first it was wonderful
we need to get that back
[Music]
good morning good morning I came here
yesterday and I asked everyone to be
open and honest and the first time I
heard any honesty last night was with
your mother not easy that is it
I um don't condone your behavior
my behavior was what
I just felt like you're like the
language that you used wasn't that of an
English gentleman like I would expect
I'm deeply sorry about that what
language did I use a lot of F words
um I don't appreciate you using that
language with my angel of a mother and
my sister can I just stop you there
because you're over exaggerating a
little bit
because I'm not going to give you
brownie points standing in front of your
mother telling me how upset you are when
you're laughing giggling with me at the
same time
you see it as it is if you have to call
it as it is I like the fact you're
standing up so it takes me to swear for
you to step up and act like a man
please you don't know [__]
did you just curse that's disgusting
Behavior young man if you want to have a
little chat with me later together one
and one I'd love that but stop being a
hypocrite
you've just sworn in front of your
mother that was a mistake and I
apologize mom
the hours you turn in four o'clock in
the afternoon I don't know how you can
call that a full day's work Gina was
frustrated the fact you don't commit
staff get no direction and you walk
around shaking cocktails but I don't
need to prove to you
no ask you to prove it to me
father put you in charge of the
restaurant so the big question is what
is your son Zach doing here my view was
he was going to come
help me run the restaurant
he's not even going to
feedback or talk to Gina or even just
asking service to not chew gum yes it
concerns me a great deal okay
we move on I've got something really
important to tell you please yes it's
something you're not familiar with
it's called feedback
well let's hear it I spent some time
this morning just traveling around
driving thinking contemplating and
popping into local places fly fishermen
locals houses cabins you name it I went
there the sad news is they didn't want
to come and sort of
tell you to your face because it's a
small community but I've got the
feedback
my daughter had a wedding reception held
at the lodge we would go back and
celebrate but over the years things have
gone downhill
Dave makes us very very unwelcome and
he's pushed the town away it doesn't
feel like they want us there
the owners seriously well needs help
he's a total horse's butt he has no idea
how to handle employees or his customers
there was a time the community rallied
round to help them but he showed no
appreciation so it didn't last very long
after time he was a jackass again
couldn't care less too bad so much
potential there
maybe they don't care
I don't know why everybody thinks I'm a
horse's ass I guess I am huh
I try to be friendly to people and I
treat them just like I treated you they
come across cold and
arrogant you come across controlling
and you come across assertive yeah we
need to get them on our side whether we
like it or not
their last comment to me was that if you
are prepared to change and commit to
change then they would walk through
those doors
uh Dave I just want to spend a couple of
minutes with you do you mind
thank you guys thank you
why does that get so defensive like that
I think insecurity
maybe
um guys can you just give me five
minutes please in fact let's go outside
in fact let's jump in the car
I mean honestly
I'm here to help yeah
you come across so withdrawn I don't
know what to do about that where did
that level of negativity come in well it
started when I first broke ground here
when all the locals started attacking us
and trying to shut us down you know you
have to put your head down start
swinging but then you were successful
you know we were successful and then I
hired a shitty chef and then they all
took off and went away and then I found
a good chef and some of them came back
but I can't
please them all the time sure but it's
not all about the Chef Dave is you have
to take part of responsibility you know
so these people leave
um and they let you down you know at the
end of the day that's on your shoulders
right yes
they dealt with that tragic loss of the
Sun and that took her a long time
did you seek help when you lost your son
no did who did you talk to no one no one
you just came back into work yeah the
next day the next day there was no one
here
I mean how did you get through how well
I just get through you know
you go day by day time time helps heal
you know but there's a hole in your
heart that never heals right yeah you're
never going to yeah
but have you expressed this to do to him
that that's how you've dealt with it
because I think she's a little bit in
the dark I think she struggles to read
you know maybe I just deal with it by on
a daily basis you know there's not a day
goes by I don't think of my son and the
loss but you know you you move on you
know I still have to make a learning I
still have to take care of DD's feelings
in the kids and all of that you know the
kids got spoiled in the process because
we cuddled them a little bit and that's
obvious and the exact's a product of
that but yeah you know I come from I
believe that they should earn it yeah
but I'm in a situation and I have been
in a situation where my wife doesn't
agree with that philosophy so it's a
constant friction in the same way with
managing our restaurant and our business
she comes in here and wants to coddle
employees and doesn't expect them to
hold the standards and I come in and I
try to get them to hold the standards
and I'm an [__] and we have Conflict
at home so as a result of that I've
tried to minimize the conflicts and let
Zach deal with the restaurant because
that's where most of our conflicts were
the business may have suffered I may
have been an [__] on occasion I don't
know what to do about that you know she
she doesn't understand my personality
but I'm sometimes I take no prisoners
and it offends people and DD doesn't
understand that mindset she's more of a
all fluff you can't build this thing
like that you're a tough [__] on the
outside if you have a heart and you can
show emotion
I have a big heart
then people need to sit
[Music]
um I'd like to talk to you about
something that's been missing
when you built this place we started off
so well didn't we yeah so I've put
something together that I think will
help reinstate that love yeah bring that
back to the Forefront let's have a look
wow who's that there yeah look at that
hair yeah man what happened
look at that
wow
talk about handcrafted even the boys
we've got a little they are yeah that's
rare Dave's smiley yeah that is rare
that that would have freeze that one
there
oh man
incredible
you know sometimes it's easy to forget
this is why you built this amazing Lodge
for the family right Didi yes yeah chalk
smear yeah
uh look at that that's a picture I
haven't seen forever we need to frame
that one on the wall
[Music]
these are the most amazing pictures
beautiful
something quite magical about that first
fish right
Dede we see those amazing pictures or go
through your mind
oh just just the memories and dreams
that we had you know and everything just
getting better and better and better you
know
and then just enjoying the property all
of our life right
it's a Stern reminder to why you built
this place I just watching your face
light up reminiscing in some of those
amazing times it's so nice to see in
here
I didn't see it when I arrived
and that's what's been missing yeah
those were good times when we look back
at the pictures that are building the
place it brings back that energy that we
had then and it really does mean
something you know we had we've raised a
family here we've we raised our kids
here all those memories were good
memories so it's always been worth
fighting for if for me she needs to fall
back in love with it
but more importantly with each other
yeah
how important
is this to you both
it's everything it's the world yeah it's
the world to us it's all we have when
it's done and said you know we spend our
best years building this place and
running it you're confident we can get
back there
you've got it in you
yeah yeah oh I felt so much better
because now we're
moving past all the bad things and we're
starting to take a look towards the good
things
after boosting the spirits of Didi and
Dave it was time to elevate the lodge
itself
my team spent all night working to turn
the Anglers Lodge into a destination
worthy of his Rich family Legacy let's
go I can't wait to show the family what
we've done in you go please
oh
enjoy wow look at that come on jump in
wow
oh my gosh wow look at that
gun is That Hideous blood color
um inviting gorgeous
let's start off with that amazing
reclaimed wood the bed spreads brand new
oh I love it can you carpets just
beautiful is it yeah
I think you've uh you've opened our eyes
to what the place can be it's you've
done a great job
gorgeous beautiful it's amazing it was
just like a new Joy kind of like when we
opened it up the first time it was like
a brand new Joy it's something that we
can reach for after going through such
hard times so we know what to do now
look at the rocking chairs
nice we don't even want to leave oh
she's beautiful
[Music]
hello hi guys good you guys here to
check in yes great wow oh my gosh hi
Alex how are you good to see you
you should see what they did to the
rooms today it's amazing I've created a
delicious new menu perfect for this
region and my team have been training
the staff non-stop to prepare them for a
successful relaunch tonight here is our
dinner menu I've invited the locals back
and a local food critic so the lodge can
rebuild these important relationships
and get their reputation back on track
everybody's attention just for a second
our critic is sitting watching paying
attention to everything that's going on
thank you
hello we just wanted to welcome you all
to the lodge and I hope you're enjoying
your evening and we appreciate you all
coming in and trying us again and uh
love to have you back can't beat the
setting of course and from now on our
food's going to match all those things
so hope you're having a great time
really nice to have everybody back okay
welcome have a great time
one shortage right up here
what are you doing
right right now it's going
three ribeye
and then you're doing short rib and we
send the appetizers
look look at me
Gina Gina come here man come here you're
not even helping yourself you're not
talking to me and you're just going into
one okay I'm gonna force you to talk
Okay so
Gina are you okay I'm okay sure I
promise okay good again ask that you can
serve the soup all right would you
please
absolutely okay soup boiling we send the
soup with one nice kale salad so next up
art dress me a kale salad no no I've got
the salad okay why can't he make the
salads never ask me this difficult but
you can't work on your own
I've worked on my own many times chef
Gina Gina come here come here
are you listening or you're giving up no
no I know I told you cannot work on your
own you just I work on my own all the
time is it best you go now no you can't
work on your own you're gonna sink this
place get a grip
okay it's not difficult
next ticket
um yeah FYI and that's nice Gina's
struggling yeah Kurt stepped up art
stepped up uh but with a menu that easy
if your mind's not in that uh you know
you've got no chance
kale salad in the window table 26 seat
one
I did salt pepper
art take over please uh Gina take a step
back art Juno's on the desserts let's go
okay I got chicken in the oven
so were those three apple crisps in the
oven oh you forgot them they are in the
oven Chef yeah uh Donnie reheating a
dessert I expect you to nail that's your
table you know that nice and gently yes
sir off we go roasted chicken with the
crispy skin
and we can't do a scoop of ice cream
no answer we can't do a scoop of ice
cream it's cold in the middle okay stop
stop oh you should take your open off
okay go home
art
take over please okay
how's my desserts ready roll
it's not working is it I'm just nervous
no it's not working
you know it's not working I'm not gonna
shout I'm not gonna scream it's just
it's unfair it's unfair in you and it's
unfair in the lodge
you're sending
a short rib to a table that we haven't
even sent the starters
you're destroying the lot
I've got a Critic that's just landed one
mistake like that and this place is
going to close heard understood I'd like
to finish out the evening
see how it goes it's not working
if you're going to go back in that
kitchen what are you going to do
differently
what's the point
I want to keep working so that I can get
it down stop listening
do not listen you're not even you're not
prepared to take any advice any help no
it's been a long time Chef since
somebody was telling me exactly what to
do and it's different for me we can't
continue like this
there's no point in fighting this yeah
sure
oh man okay
[Music]
Dave Gina just not up to speed yeah if
you can't work with this menu it's not
going to happen so yeah the good news is
Art and Curt already up to speed already
yeah yeah that's good uh good feedback
for the customers incredible I'm really
good he was very happy loved
everything's compliments all around not
a single complaint straight any
difficult questions from the critic
nothing different at all no he was uh
he's very friendly very nice and just
really enjoying everything he's like
this was simple and it was beautiful it
was perfect awesome nice good night
right it was really good happy I am
happy very happy that's nice I'm just so
happy to have it that's so nice to see
you back in here yeah well I mean
they're happy right yeah that's the most
important thing but there's one tiny
Missing Link
someone that I've arranged for all three
of you to meet her background is
extraordinary she knows the area inside
out and I've asked her to come here for
a month and help set this place up and I
want you to benefit from her knowledge
please welcome Emily Brown how are you
I'm Emily
pleasure Zach hi Emily nice to meet you
today welcome nice to see you welcome
well good to see you
um first of all she knows this business
inside out and it's excited work as a
consultant for a month and help set this
place up for a very very busy season
yeah I've heard all about you guys
really excited to get you guys where you
really need to be so welcome
um I want you two to do something you
haven't done for a long time I'd like
you to take your dear lady and go and
have dinner oh that is won't that be
nice tonight Zach's got a table for you
oh that'd be great excellent it's the
first time I'm holding hands oh
my God yeah
I think Dave's smiling it's like the
pressure's lifted off
the love is rekindled for sure
and I'm really excited to have everybody
in Island Park start coming back again
and being excited about the logic they
were when we first built it
my time is done
you guys have a great spark here trust
me you need to show it don't stop good
night God bless thanks bye thank you so
much
here's to me and you man cheers
yeah to a new Lodge
wow what a nice
that's better
man that's cold out there
this is a [__] handbrake
gear stick on the steering wheel
[Music]
I shouldn't drive [__] useless
[Laughter]
after I left the lodge
the family embraced the many changes and
is excited about the future
both Didi and Dave have rekindled their
passion you're doing good honey we're a
good team and I'm enjoying working
together to make Anglers Lodge the place
to be once again
I'm in Florida to have a struggling
Hotel on the beach a young owner Abba
Helm who has no control over his staff
what is that oh boy why it's like that I
have no idea I'm faced with many
challenging situations and it stinks in
here this is filthy really bad and I'm
unsure if I can turn this place around
your Chef has shut down I can't work
like this I want to go now I want to get
the [__] out of here
[Music]
thank you
midway between Orlando and Miami on
Florida's Atlantic Coast lies the small
town of Fort Pierce home to the
beachfront Inn and Inlet
owner Brian Paul opened it in 2012 after
running his family's successful local
fish market with his brother my job
before the inlet was the CEO the head of
my dad's Fish Market my Dad ran a
business like a uh a real leader he had
so many friends
pillar of the community everybody loved
them and I always knew as a child I
wanted to have my own place
[Music]
I think Brian has a lot of schooling
under his belt I'm not exactly sure that
he has any hotel experience
Brian as an owner is
physically here sometimes
he's just like kind of wanders around
Brian is a little too easy going if it
was me I'd have my hands nose eyes and
ears and everything and
I don't see him doing that
Brian definitely has a lot of friends
that work here some of which have taken
advantage of him in the past I believe
that Chef Ben probably has taken most
advantage of him
I want a beer
oh we're having a tasty beer tonight
boys
Ben is a uh an awesome guy I've known
him forever we've been friends forever I
give him plenty of space I help him
whatever he needs but I don't muddle in
his Affairs down there I think that the
issue here has been our lack of
consistency with our food and I mean
that directly has to be attributed to
the executive chef you know his name is
Ben
I feel like the inlet and the beachfront
both by act direction we're trying to be
too many things at once a nightclub a
bar a restaurant a hotel a wedding venue
a concert venue a place to do your
Christmas party at I mean ah the
military secret we have some guests and
employees hooting and hollering until
the wee hours of the morning and that's
out of control that's got to stop it's
bad for business Brian has to refund
hotel guest money because of noise
complaints
[Music]
I think this place has so much potential
and so much to offer we don't want to
see it fail we don't want to see Brian
fail he definitely needs to step up and
help us all out to help him he needs to
grab those reins and start start seeing
the damage that's happening and start
fixing it
today I'm in the beautiful coastal town
of Fort Pierce Florida just looking
around you're surrounded by stunning
beaches Marine is full of deep sea
fishing boats this place is gorgeous
look at this place
it looks like the hotel's closed down
hello
anybody in well
how are you I'm very on D thank you
first name is Liza Liza good to see you
how are you doing today who's is this
the boss man caught it and where's the
other half gone maybe they ate it is a
pair of shoes couldn't tell you what'd
you use it for I don't use it for
anything actually wow and what's that up
there that was what was I got here
believe it or not that's for sale
apparently so so he went onto the beach
picked up some Driftwood and then dipped
it in some varnish yep
22 stop same as that one over there no
insane no have you sold any of these
never
seriously and how much for the t-shirts
between 12 dollars for employees and 18
for guests so staff have to pay for
their own t-shirts yes and for the
guests they're 18 yes wow so when was
the last time you sold a t-shirt I sell
them every day but mostly to um the
employees the employees yes how long you
been here the establishment's been here
almost three years I've been here almost
three years as well what's wrong with it
from your point of view noise levels you
know especially the one directly above
the restaurant that what kind of noise
because it's not the the music and the
people the foot traffic everybody
hanging out at the bar and things of
that nature so that goes on directly
underneath yes they end up being
refunded and then they end up putting us
on blast on all of these you know
websites and social media and just bad
reviews left and right
housekeeping come back
touch base with the housekeepers
um just out of interest it's Gordon here
I've just checked in how far away are
the [__] rooms I mean you sound like
you're miles away
hello Madam
I'm scared her so room 16. yes and where
is it please die I'm gonna direct you
right this way what's that thing there
we grill our wings on it
you grill your wings on it yes how often
do you grill wings in there every
stinking
fact I think there's a Wing left in
there
when was that grilled chances are could
have been yesterday those are the extra
crispy ones and who's responsible for
this
the kitchen handles all of this end of
it of course
you found another charbroiled and these
were done yesterday I believe so and
they cook every day on here yes I know
the customer's still alive
oh [__] right room 16.
this is your Caribbean building the
Caribbean
Caribbean Caribbean yes what part of
this resembles the Caribbean
I think it's more so because of the view
oh the view right here sir thank you
very much you're very welcome enjoy
thank you thank you wow
oh
look at this wow
it stinks in here there's a very sort of
damp musty smell bloody hell
oh the bed feels like it's 15 years old
really bad
absolutely disgusting
180 divide for this [__] all
well mini bar
consisting of absolutely [__] freezer
over Frozen and defrosted about 10 years
ago what a mess
[Music]
I know when I'm coming to fix a business
they have various issues
but right now with the information I
have I am not impressed with how Brian
as an owner is operating this hotel
hello hello welcome to the inlet so you
must be Brian I am sorry the hotelier
and the 34 year old I do it uh you do it
all
is that what you are seriously 34 right
you know what I'm 33.
I work so hard I think I just thought I
was 34. you're 33. hey
um did you call this building the
Caribbean yes have you ever been to the
Caribbean yeah which part uh Bahamas and
this has been modeled on the Bahamas
correct do you smoke when you're in the
Bahamas you like that I've tried a
couple times surely stop yeah yeah and
that's what hotel in the Caribbean or
the Bahamas were you running before you
bought this one so I've just visited the
Caribbean I've never ran a hotel in the
Caribbean so you just go buy yourself a
25 bedroom hotel on the beach with a bar
and all I know how to do is run a fish
market when I open this and I push it up
from the scratch from the ground up it's
the fish it's fresh obviously from the
market they're so fresh right I better
jump in can I show you to your table uh
yes why not yeah
table for you right here excellent thank
you yeah all right please
I'm excited for the fresh fish
this is so surreal bro Gordon Rams and
dining room that's with the main tanks I
mean you're the owner right I think I
should lead by example so I I like to
wear mine that way if I tell them that
they need to wear them then they can't
say well Brian you don't wear yours
right I'm starving I'm gonna give you
some food right away I'm gonna get you a
great server okay grace
how are you doing nice to see you
Kelly how long you been here
and um why do the staff have to buy the
t-shirts um I don't I was never told
even our first shirts our name tags
yeah
we have to pay like eight dollars never
seen it before eight dollars a name tag
twelve dollars for t-shirt that's twenty
dollars if we come to [__] work
wow
as I look at the menu I notice it's
absolutely massive so I decided to order
the chicken wings which honestly I
wasn't surprised when they were dry
then I had the lobster mac and cheese
which technically isn't mac and cheese
because they use penne pasta but the
worst part of my lunch was the tuna
burger which I knew wasn't quite right
is that fresh
it is frozen oh it's frozen yes hold on
you said Fish Market fish fish daily
frozen fish fresh fish what's going on
we use frozen sometimes sure and you
have a fish market that you buy from
yeah yep yeah
um I'm confused ever since about four
months ago everything was fresh
everything I ran up a little bit of a
bill with my brother so we cut back and
started ordering some of the Frozen
stuff from some of the purveyors and
what's the feedback we get some negative
feedback
you guys have one
I know it's I'll blow to the ego but
you knew it was gonna be something I
think it was gonna be everything
um explain this monstrosity what in the
[__] is going on here
this is our kiosk kiosk and effort and
products for all sorts of people so
volleyballs volleyballs uh beans stick
bags
how busy is this how was it going I
honestly uh it doesn't do that good how
many beach towels have we sold not too
many beach towels show me one all right
love to see one please
what a [__] disaster
we're on the beach and we don't have
towels what is wrong with this picture
how was lunch
okay okay it's not good enough
I thought we lost you
thank you very much whenever you're
ready to go to the beach whatever I'm
ready to go to the beach wow how did you
have to stop
one
you got it
store okay can you charge out to my room
please yes sir so we sold out now
yes yeah wow jeez
at lunch I was very disappointed that
Brian falsely advertises fresh fish on
his menu I want to learn more about how
involved he is as an owner during an
evening at the beachfront checking in
Susan Addison can I go ahead and show
you off with something to drink okay
smoke them if you got him
okay man hey Chef uh just give us a
little quick run through how the alarm
works well normally I run the pass in
Expo Chef I'll take care of this boom
boom boom uses the pass through the
saute gun and then the fry guy working
with Ben I can't really tell you what he
does where's Brian
don't know chef and Brian would just
avoid him instead of trying to get to
the root of the problem and I think that
in itself is a problem
how long have you been here since last
December oh wow so you've been here a
long time yeah in your mind what do you
think the major problems are lack of
consistency as a matter of fact and lack
of structure yeah I saw that lunchtime
yeah I found out about the fish not
being so fresh how can you not sell
fresh fish when you're on the beach
that's our motto fresh fish so how many
do you think understand that we're
selling frozen fish they probably don't
no because I don't think the servers are
telling them meanwhile the customers
disappear yeah thank you great update
thank you
Brian how many of these customers in
tonight know that you're serving frozen
food you know they don't really know how
the uh the market works so probably none
of them I don't know how the market
Works they don't understand how are you
good how are you do you think we'll be
serving frozen food tonight or fresh
fish fresh fresh why fresh
but why don't you explain to them
tonight that you change things four
months ago and we're not serving fresh
fish anymore we're serving Frozen
man up so uh just a few months ago we
switched from some of our fresh product
to some of Frozen Seafood products why
would you do that they're quality
products they just aren't the best the
quality that you would expect from you
know the Pelican seafood market that
quality Frozen products yeah it's a cost
thing so
up to somewhere like this for being on
the beach of course I would hope have
fresh fish where is this [__] freezer
who's around here
right down here Gordon
this is the Frozen bit here what's that
Frozen avocado are we not in Florida
and you can't make fresh avocado
dude this is [__] where's the freezer
main walking
wow wow wow when was the last time you
were in here I come in here once a week
at least and I want to wanna you know
just kind of look around or whatever
what is this
wow
oh man
look at that the water's gone slimy and
you come in here once a week yeah
what is that
oh boy
ow what is that
pina colada
pina colada why it's like that I have no
idea it's faster it's it's off it's
bubbling
oh man that's terrible [__] trash please
trash
James I'll do trash please now pina
colada right down the drain by the
bucket load in the walk-in fridge
I mean who in the hell off price like
this
Gordon this is Chef Ben's job he's the
executive chef he's the executive chef
and you've made him that Executive Chef
Ryan sure I did
how'd you feel now
what's that tuna burger that's from the
burger yes it is oh my gosh seriously
bacon it's gone it's it's off fresh
produce on top of old produce moldy and
this one ribeye ribeye defrosting what
is this those are the smoked grilled
chicken wings before they go onto the
char grill oh my gosh and what is in
this one
you are kidding me
so underneath in that bucket's what
cooked product cooked chicken and on top
of it is what
it's raw raw chicken on top of cooked
chicken I had them for lunch
I am at a [__] loss do you know the
best way out of this is just to shut the
place down
it's not an option for me
what's that in there Ben those are
marinated chicken wings yeah underneath
next box
there's our smoke rule number [__]
one
Ben
I know Chef I didn't do it
you know I turn my back for a minute and
this is the kind of [__] that happens I
walked in and it was bedlam
[Music]
he's telling me this is your fault
you've got no idea I am at a absolute
[__] loss
I can't work like this this is huge
you now are running a restaurant cross
contaminated
[Music]
Joey yeah Chef who's responsible for
this
um we all are the entire kitchen is yeah
rule number one if you can't put hot
food in a [__] walking it doesn't
even go together no not at all nowhere
near each other I guarantee you when it
was put in there after I marinated it
they weren't shuffled
I can give you 12 more issues in there
that are bad I mean you are heading for
a [__] massive disaster
I mean who the hell put them on top of
the the other ones everybody in here
knows better haven't you trained
everybody to know that I mean
all I'm getting right now is excuses the
kitchen needs direction from the chef
the staff need direction from the owner
and your buddies can someone come up
with a [__] solution
I'm gonna go in 86 the wings sort it out
quickly
come on guys
86 Wings someone put raw [__] chicken
wings on top of cookies it wasn't me
somebody else did it 86 Wings is the
only thing I can do right now what in
the [__] is going on I was baffled in a
maze the words out of Ben's mouth were
oh I cleaned that cooler regularly every
day
[Music]
you want me to go in there and pull
everything out clean it that is not your
job to wipe the ass an executive chef I
I know that there were weeks you
wouldn't show up maybe three days a week
why didn't Brian step up Brian
he may be oblivious to some of this
stuff they've known each other since
they were young guys so you know this is
crazy so Ben goes AWOL Brian does
nothing about it the place starts
falling apart and then he just step
[__] when he wants pretty much pretty
much but if this is your business you
wouldn't tolerate that yeah I was all
for fine then two months ago so I mean
no excuse for that walk-in like that so
I'm sorry I just couldn't hold back
anymore he doesn't he doesn't come to
work that's the reason why it looks like
that okay that is absolutely the reason
why
if he's here by 12 and he leaves by five
we're lucky
I'm just I'm not sure he's just telling
me the truth I'm I'm I'm here to tell
you the truth you're not telling me this
I promise you I'm going to tell you the
truth the only way to really truly
identify a chef before you even taste
these foods to open up he's walking that
speaks volumes for any chef he's a chef
that's given up and going through the
motions sometimes I feel that way we've
been through a lot I know he's got a lot
on his place he's incompetent and he's
taking your [__] business down
you know I don't think he's incompetent
you [__] mess and the sad thing is
that your staff and your management and
your team see it and you're the only
person that doesn't know what's going on
and this is the way you want to run your
business yeah oh you do not need my help
[Music]
I swear
what's up funny people
[Music]
[Applause]
wow that's loud that music it is loud oh
man how are you doing yeah I just need a
little piece of quiet
um
that's crazy no yes it is I mean it's
like the blind leading the blind in
there because there's no discipline
yeah I do now Ben's checked out Brian's
never checked in and uh they're all
blaming each other yeah I do know
there's no there's no discipline there's
no communication there's none of it
what's the problem with him stepping up
and
dealing with issues maybe it has
something to do with the fact that he
he's not fully
experienced in certain departments are
they hosting concerts are they is a frat
party hangout is it a college I mean how
can they call themselves a hotel that's
that's the difference that's the part
that we need to try to separate and I've
been saying it for a while yeah I'm
sorry excuse me good evening beach front
end Liza speaking how can I help you
room 20
[Music]
20 does and it smells like smoke and uh
my my friend here Gloria is having a
really bad reaction
steroids and it's supposed to be a
non-smoking room
I'll be right with you
Ryan there's two guests have checked in
upstairs okay
uh she's uh she's got an issue with
analogy because the room stinks of smoke
it'd be nice to just come up and see
them or try and calm the situation out
so the lady's got an allergy and she's
already had to take a steroid and her
eyes are streaming and she's not very
happy okay hello hello so are you okay
yeah I'm fine sure any issues
sorry we had water all over the floor
we've also all over the floor
refrigerator there's water on the floor
oh no really I just cleaned it up with a
towel yeah I'm sorry
damn I walked out it was completely all
the way to the bed
Wow Let's uh let's let's come back later
on the ladies her eyes are streaming do
excuse us ladies
are you decent
sorry I've got the owner here
oh really
yeah
oh [__] there you go it's just my eyes
are tearing when was that cleaned last
that's a uh that's really a daily thing
that um daily it should be sure yeah
absolutely that is not daily uh look at
that
that's why
Jesus
as you can see
you know one of the poor ladies broken
out
the back of my throat is all scratchy is
there an alternative room we can use for
ladies I'll double check right away have
a drink downstairs a little bite to eat
but we can sort something out
one night
the big problem here is that there's no
direction for the hotel for the
restaurant for the Gazebo not even for
the car park Ben is like a headless
chicken that's checked out and Brian's
like this scared school kid that is not
qualified to run a [__] beach bar let
alone a hotel on a beach so
foreign
[Music]
am I wrong I feel like we blew it
tonight oh man it's just this is what it
is you know we'll uh don't worry man
[Music]
oh for God's sake
after a very frustrating night I woke up
this morning hopeful that Brian would be
eager to admit his faults at the
beachfront
that wasn't the case even after a staff
meeting none of the problems are sinking
in with Brian so I reached out to his
brother Eric who is continuing to fund
the business and I'm hoping Brian can
start to see the damage he has done
guys thanks for coming in
why is Ramsey here
your brother just asked you a question
why did you call me here I've got uh a
lot of issues that I need to take care
of you don't look like a man that's in
pain you don't look like a man that's
struggling you don't look like a man
that's lost control you look like you're
bouncing around having fun the business
is hurting you're hurting your brother's
business and you're not realizing it it
does reach a ceiling where where Brian
you're gonna have to get cut off
I will I'll respect it but you gotta let
me know how much time and I'll I'll make
it I'll make it
two more months and then that's it
two months
here's my promise
I will focus so hard and I'll be able to
pay you in eight weeks
I'll pay you in eight weeks I'll pay you
in eight weeks
30 grand
you gotta You You You Gotta Give Me You
Gotta Give me 90 days I mean you got to
give me 90 days
he just giving you eight weeks you just
asked for 12 weeks
you can't continue depending on your
little brother's cash
float your dreams
I just need you to make sure not to
screw this one up again
I'm not gonna screw it up
I'm not convinced I'm
not you're lucky he's your [__]
brother
Eric I got you eight months eight weeks
eight weeks of your cut off that's all
there is to it man
how important is your reputation to you
that's the most important thing in my
world and on a scale of one to ten your
reputation in this town now I gave
myself a good a good eight a good eight
good good strong age absolutely so these
are customers that have gone out their
way to spend their hard-earned cash
supporting your business you must
recognize a few of these faces
absolutely I do let's start off with the
lady in the blue shirt you know her very
well hey play hi Brian how'd you know
each other I'm Mark at Bryan you're a
spokesperson for that business yes can
you be honest with this one yes I can
the service is very
bad
I've brought people here I've been up at
the bar myself trying to order even just
a water that's been tough
do you not listen to the advice in terms
of sloppy service
I I absolutely I listen I do listen I do
listen I do listen do you offload that
to your team
no I don't I don't so that's why it's
not dealt with
sir your experience we ordered our
chicken sandwich when the chicken
sandwich came out it was raw it was raw
and it was mushy in the middle I could
have got sick from that
and I love your bar because I could come
here late night and I can get free
drinks so for me and two for my buddy
and paid for one we got five
wow
unbelievable so my first experience here
was a Super Bowl party that you
advertised and actually had some out of
town guests food was very mediocre the
crab cakes were like sawdust they were
horrible that night after the game was
over a couple Rowdy fans started a
little brawl we had drinks thrown on us
wow the other thing I'd like to say is
if I'm staying on the ocean I love to
fall asleep with the window open and
hear the ocean
you can't do that here you hear music
all night long
I honestly stayed here myself once I
tried to call down because our sheets
were dirty you couldn't even call like
nobody answered and literally I think
the biggest problem for me is the mixed
message it's like are you a bar or are
you a restaurant because they're paying
150 for dinner however there's people
walking in in bikinis drunk
uh
listen this feedback has been crucial
anything you'd like to say
thank you guys you guys rock man thank
you I'm telling you make you proud I
promise you
let's go
it's not a time for high-fiving I'm
[__] embarrassed what the [__] you
hugging them for I know that they care I
do know they care a raw chicken sandwich
but that's not an
that is not an eight out of ten and do
you think they're set up do you think
this is a TV show or not we're just
gonna spout off these people aren't
exaggerating they're real they're real
customers
you're turning into a laughing stock
yeah I know it's not good the jury's out
with me I've never come this far and
still sat on the fence in an undecided
way but [__] listen up and listen
carefully the partying the free-for-all
I'm paying for wandering they're giving
me five
in front of your eyes
tomorrow
you turn up here looking like an owner
understood you got a lot on your plate
but get your head out the [__] clouds
and get real
[__] off I've got this Gordon
I'll show you
even though I wasn't won over by Brian's
commitment I went ahead and designed a
new concept for the beachfront
my team and I completely overhauled the
rooms and added a beach club to the
unused outdoor space I'm really hoping
Brian can see the potential he has to
offer
[Music]
morning good morning well I wish it was
a good morning what did I ask you to
come into work today what did I say was
the one thing I said to you come in as a
bus a boss
right now
you look like a towel boy
I mean sunglasses around your neck
badge on there shorts on there who are
you give me the name badge
[Music]
stand out from the crowd you're the
owner
I've had a really rough night and so is
my team get out of here get changed and
come back like an owner now [__] off
ready
honestly
hurry up no no no no no no I'm not
listening
Gordon I'm coming back like a boss I'm
ready to make this whole Fort Pierce
Community proud Gordon get out of there
seat belt on
no doors and no seat valve oh my God
[Music]
I'll be back I'll be back I'll be ready
Brian returned looking like an owner and
I'm hoping that translates into his role
as a boss let's go Joey Quick Step let's
go it's time to reveal to Brian and his
staff the newly renovated beachfront Inn
and Inlet oh my God
first of all this is not the spring
break hangout that's gone wrong this is
a proper beach front room sweet
oh yeah so Inlet oh my God whoa the
floor I love it it's
perfect but you've got a tangible asset
here that can help live this business
and more importantly start making money
awesome Brian you need to get a grip of
this business and you need to realize
you know what's at stake here I need to
be convinced I need to see you stepping
up as a boss Ben and Jerry we're
relaunching that Russian tonight so I'm
going to go through that menu jump
downstairs get organized and start
finding your way let's go
oh man
after observing dinner service
I saw the beachfront kitchen wasn't set
up to handle such a massive menu so I
redesigned a smaller menu that is easy
for Ben to execute
okay guys small menu let's run from the
top appetizers lobster mac and cheese
done with the correct pasta Ben steam
clams again great showing for the table
Wings off the smoker so it stays nice
and crisp
and a chicken cobb salad entrees pan
seed scallops easy three says ahi tuna
fresh and then of course the Mai Mai
it's small it's inviting and tonight
I've just been told that we've got the
mare in for dinner there's one person we
can reach out to to send the message
back in the community this is it
dig in
that sauce is fabulous oh my God
wow
it's time to relaunch the beachfront
I've put a plan in place and I'm really
hoping Brian can finally show me that
he's ready to run his business all right
everybody listen up
tonight is a big service there's not
many opportunities like this
you have to take advantage of it I need
you guys all to get together right now
and bring it in one two three
Prime Brian let's just get real for a
couple of seconds yeah yes sir you
forgot the [__] most important thing
tonight
who is in for dinner tonight you haven't
even told the staff possibly the most
important person in this town we have
the mayor in the night you guys the
mayor and that's just not something that
happens every [__] week you have to
bring it together tonight you have to
work as a team sort out guys we're
opening in five minutes
come on
[Music]
checking in afternoon all right welcome
to the inlet good evening good evening
this is lovely
um enjoy dinner an amazing array of
appetizers and the entrees are to Die
For Tourists in the hair slow and steady
wins the race
so first they get on yes good
Hi how are you welcome hi guys
sitting here
oh where well they were gonna they were
gonna give it a choice when I sit inside
or outside it's her choice
welcome how are you thank you for coming
in thank you guys it's an absolute
pleasure I'll leave you in hands of our
manager owner Brian follow me guys
welcome back good to see you sir Mike
wise
okay guys
all right mayor wherever you like inside
I got a chicken burger ready at your
leisure chicken burger
spent as Brian told you the medicine no
no he has not I'm real
yeah Brian
your Chef doesn't even know the mayor's
in ah if you don't think he deserves to
know because he does come on man Ben yes
the mayor's in at table seven third
table seven
am I good Ben
I've got that blackened chicken for you
and that's it Ben you need to be the
captain and right now
I'm not convinced let's get serious
about this business and do this is the
man's order in
are they sending appetizers yet
are they hit the table no I put their
food in he wanted a salad and the fried
calamari and she wanted the Mahi okay
great so again check in that's a hot
ticket tonight but do you know what's
happening in your kitchen at the moment
no look at me do you know what's
happening in there
yeah get into the kitchen find out
what's going on let's go
behind you
wow that burnt my forehead
excuse me
so what did you guys order
um I got the mahi mahi and a salad and
he got an appetizer
the mess is the only person sat with
nothing in front of her okay please
all right two Tunas
can I have a table 15s appetizers ASAP
it's the mayor 15 15. I was told seven
sorry miscommunication they settled 15
right I made a mistake okay I need two
house salads right now before anything
else right in a second
Brian didn't know what table the mayor
was at
it seems like the biggest thing Ryan
changed was his wardrobe two house are
in the window two house
and see if you can see everything he's
doing there Terry it's too much dressing
bro redo it sun is overdressed soggy as
[__] wrong dressing yes sir all I need
to hear is a bit of a voice if we go
silent we'll go down
[Music]
for tonight's relaunch of the beachfront
salad's overdressed soggy as [__] wrong
dressing I was really hoping Brian would
step up as an owner given that I put
everything in place for him to succeed
God damn it dude but his lack of focus
has me really worried that he's not fit
to run this place
your Chef has shut down I didn't realize
that you didn't realize so the first two
sellers for the mayor had the wrong
dressing on and were overdressed I said
if you taste them he said no so he
hasn't got your back when's that Penny
gonna drop they're gonna turn the corner
I will watch Ben if he doesn't come out
of it we'll switch him and Joey
how many guacamoles you guys got out
there
okay okay
hey check in 30 seconds
give me time on the mass table please
Ben table 15 yeah the mass type we sold
it calamarina Mahi did you see it before
he went I sure did I played it
everything
the man hasn't got a [__] food
Ryan
urgently come here
so Ben's told me the [__] mayor's got
their food and look at the mayor's table
there's nothing on there look at me look
at look now hey we're about to go down
yeah and I'm gonna get in my [__] car
and I get the [__] out of it if you
don't get a grip because this is a
[__] joke now you better get in there
and tell your executive chef then that
the mayor hasn't got their food and find
out where the [__] it is
Ben the mayor's not gotten her food I
put it in the window where where is it
I'll make it right now I'll make it
right now
[Applause]
it might be nice to have some food let's
try the mayor's food again
what is that undercooked that is
undercooked
what's that chicken look like to you
thank you so it's dry
um how would you describe that chicken
it looks kind of dry very dry there you
go you're not even a chef are you no no
I'm 20. thanks darling so from a 20 year
old server it's never cooked even she
spotting is dry and you're saying it's
raw let me tell you something and listen
carefully I'm going I'm packing my bags
there's that it's the worst thing we've
sent all week it's overcooked and it's
dry and then you you tell me it's raw
good night
I'm done
is unreal I mean I'm so pissed off I
can't give that guy
any more advice I can't continue to tell
him to step up and make decisions
he has a chef in there that's just
riding him and riding the business and
when you're weak you've got no chance of
running a business
and what a shame
unfucking real
all right coming around
I never like to leave a business but
Brian simply wasn't listening he missed
the deadline pain his brother back and
while it's been a slow process my advice
finally started to sink in four months
after I left he made a decision to let
Chef Ben go and hired a brand new
kitchen staff on the hotel side Brian
has made the guess a priority given the
curfew to the nighttime entertainment
hopefully now with Brian stepping up
like a boss he can lead the beachfront
in the right direction
[Music]
foreign